behind the facade of routine kitchen
work are hidden stories of rape torture
and abandonment
for years these women were abused by
isil fighters and now their lives are
they were uncertain us and raping us my
children live with that memory i now
suffer from injuries from the spine to
the neck
the shock of what she saw was so
horrific that this child lost her
ability to speak
we cannot reveal their identity as they
now face risks from their own families
some were freed by paying ransom to isil
others discovered after the armed group
was defeated in iraq
out of the thousands of abducted women
girls and boys nearly half are still
missing according to official statistics
others have been abused at camps and
abandoned by their families and tribes
they have this belief that if you have
been raped you're an isol woman
my husband spat on me and started
beating me with my brother i was
speeding so bad they had to take me to
the doctor
my husband dumped me he says you are
shamed to me
i do not want you any more you have
given your body to ice or militants he
left us alone
their suffering has not ended in
addition to being rejected by their
families and tribes even the law which
was made to compensate them seems to
have forgotten some
the yazidi survivors law was passed last
year and rights activists say there's
been little progress to implement it
it's focused on the yazidi minority
community which suffered some of the
worst atrocities
but the law fails to include other isil
victims including shia and sunni arab
women muslim arab women who were
enslaved by isil and did not find a
place to go back to they are still
living in the shadows of the society
inara's organization runs separate
shelters for yazidi and other survivors
all of them she says face societal
challenges
not less than 10 000 women where the
[Music]
where the victims of the
isil attack and this femicide is not
really acknowledged by the international
community or dealt with in a way that
that keeps the dignity or the respect or
compensates
those who were the victims al jazeera
spoke to men whose wives and mothers
were stoned to death but they say
because they're muslims there is no one
to listen to their plight
they do not want to appear on camera
because of the stigma and fear their
community will shun them too
years after they escaped omg breaks down
whenever her daughter begins to speak
my mother told him do whatever you want
to do to me but leave my daughter alone
do not marry her to one of you then they
raped my mother before my eyes and later
they raped me in front of my mother
there's no future nothing is left
still they have not given up hope for
justice they call themselves invisible
victims living in plain sight but no one
to call their own
and as they wait their families tribes
and most of the international community
continues to ignore them
osama bin laden